- I'm answering the most complicated
and maybe some of the funniest questions
that Sam picked out for me.
And huge thank you to Thrive Market
for sponsoring this video.
Are bones wet or dry?
They have blood vessels inside them.
They're blood.
There's blood, so they're wet.
Actually, they're spongy,
and if something's spongy,
it's more likely to be wet than not.
Does being slapped actually wake you up
or is that a cartoon thing?
It absolutely does wake you up.
You know what wakes you up more
than a slap, a sternal rub.
We actually do that in the
hospital to our patients.
The sternum is a bone.
If you rub it very aggressively like that,
it'll wake a patient up.
That's how we check if
they're actually unconscious
or awake or just asleep.
What is the leg version
of your armpit called?
It has a name.
Popliteal area.
See, sometimes even doctors forget terms.
It's the popliteal area.
Popliteal fossa.
Is it dangerous to eat apple stems?
My friend eats the entire apple
and I'm afraid she's
going to hurt herself.
I've never heard of apple
stems being dangerous to eat.
I know ideally you don't
want eat the seeds.
- [Sam] What's wrong with the seeds?
- I'm pretty sure they contain
some kind of anti-phytonutrient
or something.
Let's see.
Apple seeds can be indeed poisonous.
From britannica.com.
But it takes quite a
few of them to kill you,
and they have to be
crushed, blah, blah, blah.
The adult would need to
eat 150 to several thousand
to be at the risk of cyanide poisoning.
- [Sam] Wow.
Interesting.
- The more you know.
is it true that if you step on crack,
you break your mama's back or
if you step on a line break,
your daddy's spine?
I don't know what kind of
bondage question this is, but no.
I don't know why there's
drugs mentioned in this.
You shouldn't be stepping on
crack 'cause it's illegal.
You shouldn't be stepping on a line break.
I don't know what that means.
- [Dan] Do you know what this is from?
- No.
- [Dan] Oh, how funny.
It's when you walk on the sidewalk.
It's a game kids play.
Step on a crack, you
break your mother's back.
- Whoa, this is some American stuff-
- [Sam] This must be.
Yeah, I grew up here.
- You see, while these guys
were playing that game,
I was learning arithmetic.
See, my daddy was breaking my spine
if I didn't get the arithmetic right.
Barely alive.
Hey, Doctor Mike,
what do you think about
developing birth control for men?
Absolutely necessary.
There are already some options out there,
so we need to do more of that.
Do you ever use your medical
training on non-humans,
like bear?
Absolutely, Joshua.
Whenever Bear is sick,
I'm trying to figure out
what's wrong with him
in the same way that I do with a human.
Even when I go to the vet,
I ask very pointed
questions and they're like,
are you in health care?
I'm like, I'm a family
doctor and Bear's family
so you better take care
of him like family.
You get me?
April.
Should I put on sunscreen before
or after I apply my makeup?
That's a really good question.
(Sam laughing)
- Well, if we take this logically,
you want to apply the
sunscreen directly to your skin
so that it gets absorbed and does its job
protecting your body from UV rays.
Then you could put the makeup
on, on top of the sunscreen,
but the sunscreen has to come on first.
Also, remember, you have
to reapply quite often,
especially if you're
swimming and or toweling.
I love that word, toweling.
Say with me, toweling.
If your eye muscles are active all day
and during your REM
cycle, when do they rest?
It's a cycle
so they're not constantly
going throughout the night.
There are periods where
there's non-REM sleep
and your eye muscles are relaxed.
Also, it's important to
note that different muscles
have different utilities
and some need more rest than others.
Your cardiac muscle
almost never gets a break
during the short time that it relaxes,
but your heart beats maybe a
hundred thousand times a day
on average.
It's a lot of work,
and it doesn't stop when you
sleep or when you sneeze.
Myth busted.
Hey doc, are you considering
getting another tattoo?
Mia, I am.
I think I have what I want,
but I don't know where I want it.
So I'm open to suggestions.
It is text.
So feel free to text on my body right now
and send me a tweet of
what you've texted on me.
Can I use chopsticks?
Absolutely.
I'm a chopstick rockstar.
I can all day.
I can eat soup with chopsticks.
Are you on that level?
Back to the questions in
just a second, but first,
let me tell you about Thrive
Market, an online marketplace,
where you can save money
and get amazing products.
The beauty of Thrive Market is
there are thousands of items
with guaranteed savings, home, beauty,
even pet products for Bear
with a price match guarantee.
Recently, I've been using
their new auto-ship feature,
created so I never run
out of the things I need,
like these chocolate covered almonds,
one of my favorite snacks.
I love that when I'm browsing the website,
you can organize it based on the diet
or values that are important to you.
Non-GMO, fair trade certified, vegan,
whatever you need, it's there.
All orders are delivered
with carbon-neutral shipping
and their warehouses are zero waste,
a part of Thrive Market's mission
to become the world's first
climate-positive grocery store.
Choose whatever membership
best fits your lifestyle,
one month, 12 month packages.
For me, the 12 month
package at just $5 per month
is really the reasonable choice,
and that's the one I recommend
to my friends and family.
Join Thrive Market today and
get 40% off your first order
and a free gift.
All you have to do is
visit the link down below
thrivemarket.com/doctormike.
Remember, doctor is spelled out.
And if you sign up for the full year,
it's 30 days risk-free.
All right, let's get
back to the questions.
Why does your funny bone
tingle when you touch it
or whatever?
Well, if yours tingles
just when you touch it,
there's a problem.
There's some inflammation
in your cubital fossa.
In your cubital tunnel.
I'm fossa everywhere today.
In your cubital tunnel here.
When you hit your funny bone,
here's what's actually happening,
and I'm going to blow your mind right now,
'cause the funny bone ain't even a bone.
It's actually the ulnar nerve
that runs in the cubital tunnel here
that leaves your spine,
comes down your arm,
and comes and give sensation
and motor control to your hand.
And unlike regular pain,
which is like achy, throbby, sharp,
nerve pain, like if you
damage the nerve directly,
what you're getting is electrical,
shooting, awkward pain,
tingly that feels weird.
Are there certain foods or
drinks that can induce dreams
while you sleep?
I'm going to take this
question a little differently.
Medications can definitely
change the types of dreams
that you have.
I'll give you a personal example.
If I was to take Benadryl
before going to sleep,
I have the craziest, deepest dreams.
Like, I will go into a murder mystery
with Bear as my sidekick,
and him and I talk,
and we solve the mystery together.
It happened.
Victoria B.
Do lemons, make you lose weight?
Are you asking that facetiously?
If you put two lemons in your
pocket, do you lose weight?
stomach, do you lose weight?
No, lemons have nothing
to do with weight loss.
In fact, lemons, if you eat
them have calories in them.
So if you eat enough of them,
you can gain weight with lemons.
Why is it when you smell
something really bad,
it makes you want to throw up?
That's probably an evolutionary
thing that you've developed
to make you stay away from that object,
'cause nausea's a very powerful deterrent.
If it's already in your mouth,
why you throw up is because your body
probably senses something is amok there
and shouldn't be entering your body,
and actually encourages
you to get rid of it.
Can a person with epilepsy
still work in the hospital?
Absolutely.
It obviously depends
on whether or not their
epilepsy is controlled
'cause you can't be working with tools
if your epilepsy is uncontrolled.
So if you're taking the medications
and you have a documented
history of having it controlled,
you can have many jobs.
Mike, you've only broken one bone?
Why are you playing it so safe?
You're right, Neil, let
me go break some (beep).
Is there a difference between
CPR and chest compressions?
CPR just means
cardiopulmonary resuscitation.
Chest compressions are part of that.
We used to give rescue
breaths, but we realized
that there wasn't enough
benefit to doing so.
It actually stopped people
from performing the chest compressions,
which are actually the
most important thing
to increase someone's
survivability until help arrives.
Bronwyn S.
Is it safer to wear over-ear
or in-ear headphones?
Oh, I'm very passionate about this.
First of all, if you are
cycling or running outside
and there are motor vehicles around,
make sure you do not use
noise-canceling headphones.
It will save your life.
Second, if you use in-ear
headphones and you have earwax,
the earwax gets pushed further
and further, further back,
and then it starts clogging your ears,
which can lead to you
developing an infection.
When you're listening
with your headphones,
whether they're on-ear or in-ear
or over-the-ear headphones,
make sure that you're listening
to less than 60% volume,
because you will damage
your hearing over time
if you continue listening above 60%.
Doctor Mike, can you recommend
a great source of protein?
I'm trying to body build.
Zaid, it depends.
I'm a big fan of getting your
protein naturally from foods,
ideally healthy food, beans,
nuts, white meat chicken, soy,
whey protein could be an option for some,
although it doesn't vibe
with everyone's guts.
Some people do have upset stomach with it.
Does cold weather actually
give people colds?
Nope.
False misinformation.
But it does increase the
susceptibility of colds
because if you are very cold
and aren't dressed right,
that can hurt your immune system.
Also in the winter time,
the air is more dry,
therefore drying out your mucus membranes.
And the fun part that I
like to talk about most
is germ hang time.
When the air is dry,
you sneeze into the air,
the germs hang around a lot longer.
Austin Graham.
Hey, Doctor Mike, why
is eating salt so bad?
I hear about people having to
reduce their sodium intake.
It's not inherently bad.
We need to stop villainizing nutrients
because it creates so many other problems.
Here's the best nutrients, and
here are the worst nutrients.
It doesn't exist.
It depends on who you are
and what problems you have.
If you have congestive heart failure
and you already have high blood pressure,
yeah, you should monitor your salt intake
'cause that could be a problem.
But in general, be reasonable,
listen, to the guidance that
your doctor has given you
as an individual,
as opposed to reading
nonsense articles online
that usually doesn't apply to you.
Why is it when you get up
too fast you get lightheaded?
All right, fun question about
orthostatic hypotension.
Your body has a blood pressure
that it needs to maintain
in order to keep blood going
from the lower part of
your body against gravity
and feeding your brain, right?
'Cause your brain's at the top,
gravity's pulling your blood down.
When you stand up,
you suddenly need to raise your
blood pressure very quickly
in order to make sure
that the blood keeps reaching the brain.
So what your body has to do
is that's the sense that change
of pressure really quickly
and adjust by squeezing
the arteries in your legs
in order to shoot that blood
back up into your brain.
Now, now, now, now, now, now,
if you're a little bit older,
if you're a little dehydrated,
and you can't maintain a
good enough blood pressure
or you can't adjust your
blood pressure as quickly,
you will feel a little
lightheaded when you get up
and that's why you should get up slowly
and you should always have support
and make sure you don't fall.
How do you know if you
have high blood pressure?
Please answer, please answer.
I can tell you have high blood pressure
from reading your
question here in all caps.
You measure your blood pressure
using a sphygmomanometer.
- Is that how you say it?
I thought it was sphygmomanometer.
- What?
(men laughing)
Such an important point.
One elevated blood pressure measurement
does not equal the
diagnosis of hypertension
or high blood pressure.
That is simply an elevated
blood pressure reading
without the diagnosis of hypertension,
'cause it takes multiple.
Lil Davey.
Doctor Mike, I have to meet you.
When can we make this happen?
Come on tour.
Details down below.
Seriously, tickets are selling out fast,
and if you want to meet,
you gotta get a ticket.
I see those jaw trainer things on TikTok.
Do the actually work?
Bro.
Cristiano Ronaldo got paid
mad money to do that ad.
And you shouldn't really
be using these things.
Because the mass of your
muscles are really strong.
But the reality is if you overdo it,
you can create problems in the TMJ area
that literally, literally
cause you to have a pain
in the head.
Not a pain in the butt,
but a pain in the head.
And then at night, if you
overtrain these muscles,
you can start doing teeth
clenching and teeth grinding,
wearing down your molars.
You do not want these
problems, trust me on this.
I've seen patients who suffer with it.
It's a big, big problem.
Click here for a video
about birth control.
Literally, the best birth control.
And huge thanks again to Thrive Market
for sponsoring this video.
Join Thrive Market today to
get 40% off your first order
and a free gift.
Use my link to get started.
And as always, stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat hip hop music)